welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for hanging with us at the break um we
have a great candidate to introduce you
to today he is running in texas the
texas legislator district 92
salman bojani salman thank you for
coming and joining us today i want to
talk to you about texas and turning
texas blue and because my belief is is
that it's not turning a blue i i think
it actually is blue what do you think
it's actually registering people will
turn texas blue right because there's a
lot of people from the minority
backgrounds that have never ever voted
in their life actually i just had
yesterday
a lady who became a recent citizen
and she had never voted she was the
first i was the first candidate who
knocked on her door and she's voting
i've also have citizens who have been
citizens for 10 years
never registered to vote
i registered them
in in december and now i'm the first
person they're voting for so i think it
you'll see there's a lot of pockets of
minority communities that have never
been restocked by a candidate and you
know i'll tell you one thing right if
you as a candidate we look we have
limited resources we have limited time
so we're always looking at this okay
here's like 10 000 people who vote every
single time or here there's 20 000
people that have never voted
so what is my best use of the roi what
is my best roi right they'll just go
after the thousand people who have
registered a vote who have already voted
and so that's what i'm going after
everybody right right right
yeah i'm sort of expanding our universe
to increase those people who have never
voted in their life but i can resonate
with them when i knock on their door and
that's why they're coming out towards i
would say yes you know we i think the
texas is blue
it just needs we need to make sure we
register them and bring them out to vote
yeah getting it getting them getting
them engaged in that activity to get to
the ballot yeah because because in texas
there's a lot of different laws that are
changing and we'll talk about that but
tell us your background tell us because
i read i read you won your city council
election by 37 votes which is incredible
um so tell us tell us that story tell us
how you came to run for this district in
texas sure let me rewind back to you
know so i was born in pakistan um united
states when i was 19 years old and as a
young adult i worked at gas stations
mopping floors cleaning restrooms and
stocking shelves for six bucks an hour
uh was was really tough as an immigrant
you know not knowing you know everything
and and and working hard i worked 80
hours a week three jobs uh but really
blessed you know we did it with a smile
you know became a cashier then a manager
and bought my first business in 2003
then put myself through law school
because i wanted to raise the bar for my
kids because they just i didn't want
them to just do an undergrad i wanted
them to do more so i went to smu law
school in the evening program in the
morning i would go to my businesses and
in the evening i went to smu law school
and read these thick law school books
but you know graduated after four years
i'm glad i have a good family that
supported me throughout the process
because i only worked at the the
business and in the law school that said
nothing else but uh graduated uh in 2013
worked for a large law firm called
haynes and boone so i practiced law with
some of the brightest legal minds in the
country and then started my own practice
in 2015
and i do real estate and corporate law
and then 2016 when we elected a former
president that's when i felt that this
was not the right direction for america
right that where he had elected somebody
who did not resonate with us and
actually hated me and my family for
being an immigrant for being muslim
and i felt that how is this person that
prays on the divisiveness of american
society will lead a great nation and i
just was really sad okay i'm gonna do
what mahatma gandhi said be the change
that you want to see in the world right
so i put my name in the hat i ran for
ulysses city council and got a lot of
islamophobic comments like a lot of
hateful speech in fact one somebody you
know at the polls i was greeting them
and they came in a wheelchair and they
said hey you know uh i told them hey i'm
running for a city council i would
really appreciate your support on your
vote i'm passionate about giving back to
my city and he's like what kind of pork
do you eat
so i said i had to stop for a minute
like okay
what is what what did you say and she's
like he's like what kind of pork do you
eat i was like i did not know there are
so many different types of porks but i
don't need any kind of pork uh and he's
like if you don't eat pork then you
don't have my vote
so i'll say okay that's fine sir you
know with all your respect you can go
vote against me but i'm not gonna
denounce my faith or change my religion
or eat pork because you want me to do
that right i'm gonna straight to to my
values and my beliefs and my faith is
what inspires me to give back to the
community and so really bleh but you
know
we kept it very positive because i
didn't want to be negative people kept
on saying you're a terrorist or go back
to pakistan you don't belong in america
and all that i said look i'm here i
could be making money at my law firm
right or being here doing voluntary
service or being passionate about my
city and that's what i'm doing and so
you know we you know we even my state
representative jonathan stickland who's
a far-righting republican attacked me
for being muslim attacked me for being
an immigrant and said he have a
dangerous agenda and i shouldn't get
elected but we beat his hand-picked
opponent by 37 votes we knocked on ten
thousand five thousand dollars made ten
thousand phone calls and brought one
thousand first-time voters out of the
polls not just in the municipal election
they had never avoided ever in their
life and and we were able to make
history by being the first minority ever
to be elected to the yula city council
that's fantastic now i know i know i
know you got a lot of support from the
faith community not just the muslim
faith community but all the faith
community there
in your local area when you were getting
some of this pushback from um from some
of the the candidates that were
spewing the racism and i know i know
that probably felt really good to have
that support from the community yeah
interfaith actually there's an
interfaith council that's in euless
all of the priests pastors rabbis uh you
know imams all of them got together and
wrote a letter in my support so i was
really really like i mean my race really
energized them and made them united
basically so it's really really awesome
it's called faith in texas it's an
organization of interfaith leaders and
they issued a letter for me saying that
you know this hateful speech from
jonathan sicklin is not the right move
and he's elected he should be held to a
higher standard right exactly
right but again he was not always
the worst legislature in the whole texas
you know it always so he won that award
basically every time right well you know
a lot of people get this stigma about
texas because you know they say it's not
blue and they say well it's racist but
that only proves and i read i read
several articles on it it only proves
that the community was behind you
maybe not just behind your candidacy but
also behind you is hey everyone's
welcome here and everyone's welcome to
be pro-democracy because that's that's
what the kind of message that we try to
we try to promote here is pro-democracy
not just like republican democrat um i
would love to have two parties in this
country that that were really behind
democracy all the way full throated but
we don't really have that right now
unfortunately so
um
talk about talk about um why it's
important to you
that because you're working so hard i i
i noticed that you're knocking on all
these doors you're calling all these
names um and this is for a state
legislative seat this isn't like you're
running for governor or you know like
beto or you're not running for president
so what makes you want this seat in this
texas legislature why do you think it is
so important that you give your time and
your energy to public service to this
seat specifically that's a great
question so there are three reasons why
i'm running for office right first is i
really enjoyed my city council term i've
i've served three years on euless city
council again uh amazing time and worked
really well i was elected actually as
mayor pro tem for the city of euless by
not the people of euless by my
colleagues in euless so euless out of
the seven city council members i was the
only democrat and the only minority
yet my republican colleagues elected me
as a mayor pro-time for the city of that
means huge right because yeah that is
elected one of their own as a mayor pro
tem but they chose me because i would
like to build consensus right there's a
word called compromise which is not a
taboo in my books at all and i
i take fifty percent all day long right
as opposed to negative fifty percent or
negative or zero right well yeah a
hundred percent of nothing is nothing
enough exactly right so that's why i
feel so i really enjoyed my time and
then second thing is i want to really
inspire the next generation of youth to
run for office because we need to work
on the pipeline and that's what's
missing from texas like you're saying
that you know texas is blue yes it's
blue but do we have great inspiring
candidates that can energize the base
and bring them out to the polls right
it's it's good to just do a flurry
speeches but at the end you need to put
the hard work right you need to knock on
doors you need to make phone calls you
need to you know send mailers and all
that and we need candidates to do that
and so that's why we need to work on the
pipeline and see how we can get that
done third reason i'm running is i think
our leaders in austin have lost in touch
with hard-working texans like last cycle
i'll tell you they butchered our voting
rights they made it more difficult for
people to vote
people that have been voting for a
decade or long
are not going to be able to vote by mail
why because there's a small technicality
they missed on their form 50 of the mail
in ballot applications are being
rejected by the terran county it's
ridiculous and what they and what
they're saying is the state law changed
and that's therefore we need to have all
these things checked or whatever right
because i didn't mark a check they're
not going to give a million dollars
anyways i mean i feel that even the
election day should be a state holiday
like how do you expect a hard work like
i was working for six bucks an hour i
know i would not have any time for
politics like how how if i'm putting 12
hours a day putting food on the table
how am i going to do that so we need to
have more weekend list this election we
or there's only one saturday that's
voting the entire early voting or
election day it is only one saturday
election day is on tuesday so it's not
it doesn't give like people of minority
and hard-working people a chance to vote
and then we should have automatic
registration so as soon as somebody
turns 18 or somebody turns becomes this
u.s citizen they should automatically be
rested about why not right if you don't
want to register fill out a piece of
paper and say hey i don't want to
register that's fine but right so
you like the opt-out system as opposed
to the absolutely yes everyone is
eligible and you have the power to say
you know i don't wanna right because
once everybody's registered then me as a
candidate i can knock on their door
right now i have no idea who's
registered who's not i mean who i know
who's registered but i don't know who's
not registered there's no list of that
right so that's why i say texas is blue
but we need to find out who is not
registered to sort of get them
registered right and that can happen at
the in the community halls and whatnot
but again i digress so voting is voting
right is a really big issue for me and
then women's rights right our
reproductive rights are you know are
taken away from us we have the most
conservative law in our books in the
entire country and as an attorney i feel
it's unconstitutional uh so we need to
repeal sba that's the law that they
passed last cycle and then they did not
pass medicaid expansion you and i are
paying taxes to washington right now and
it's our money it should come back to
texas right it doesn't because governor
abbott has said no to medicaid expansion
and and it's a flip of a switch as soon
as you flip that switch on millions of
dollars start coming back from texas to
texas right but again that's another
issue we have five million people that
are uninsured and that's not that's not
right for our state and then the fourth
issue is that we're not paying our
teachers well uh our teachers are
getting such minimal salaries that it's
shying away a lot of good educators and
good quality educators and how are we
going to educate this whole stream of
the youth that that will make texas such
a great place to live and work if you
don't have good teachers and then lastly
and you know you know the book banning
and the crd rhetoric that's going on
yeah we've heard of it
nine superintendents have quit or
resigned because of that it's really in
just in dallas fort worth reason i'm not
talking about the state so it's in
support as a protest against this
treatment of like banning books and
burning books and all that stuff
politicizing our education system
because they they're not they're not you
know playing politics all they care
about is educating our youth right right
people let them do that without having
this book banning and all that cr
development and the last thing is fixing
electric grid we knew 11 years ago
last year
even this year they haven't fixed it if
there's another tour you know storm that
comes in
it'll be tested again and i don't know
if it's going to withstand well i mean
you could just buy plane tickets to tick
yeah right yeah but but you know in all
in all seriousness it really does um it
really does sound like that you're that
you're pro-democracy and what i mean by
that is with the opt-in the the issues
that you're talking about this is
important especially in local politics
you know because so many times being me
and gabe talk about national issues you
know we talk about the white house we
talk about the congress the senate um
the supreme court some of those national
issues but those local level issues
sometimes is where you want everyone who
can be involved to be involved because a
lot of people think oh well politics
doesn't affect me
until your electorate goes out right
right until until you you have uh
medicaid expansion affecting your the
cost of your health care in your local
communities so those things affect you
overall and right now in this country
like we were saying earlier there's only
one party that really wants to do the
hard work to compromise and do that
thing called democracy and be
pro-democracy and it seems like it's the
democrats that the republicans
want to fool around with issues like
rather oh how many weeks uh pregnancy
actually happened and had this debate um
where we could be having a broader
conversation about health care about the
electrical grid in texas
education teachers pay um you know what
actually education is and what it isn't
because it seems like people have lost
their way in that so i really appreciate
that you you had this
pro-democracy message gabe did you have
any questions i was even going to say
like you know you talked about you know
me coming to the middle 50 you know
compromise and i would say even the
things that you talked about that you
support these aren't radical things
either right it's like
education making sure that we're all
covered healthcare-wise
uh making sure that you know women are
supported you know even after the
pregnancy stage right instead of just
being like no kids and then
right no support right
um
and beyond that is just like you know
making sure that everyone has the right
to vote like these all these concepts
are labeled as radical right they're
crazy they're far left it's like no
these are
these are common rights that you should
have right it's just things that you
would assume like when we built this
country these were things that were
intended to be done for everyone not
just
one group you know
so i feel like as a candidate it's like
yeah these are no-brainers right these
are things that everyone should have and
so to have a candidate who
who holds that or to hold that up and
say like this is what i this is what i'm
standing up for this is what i represent
like i think that's great to hear and
great to see it's pretty it's pretty
easy stuff right like the voting right
it's not it's insane you know right
yeah right you're not you're not saying
you're not saying that that we should
give away free houses and free cars but
back to the voting rights because i
think this is one of the most important
um things about the two parties in the
pro-democracy uh issue that we have is
that
when you're talking about voting rights
democrats
trying to make sure that everyone votes
they're not saying they only want
democrats and people who are
left-leaning to vote they want literally
they want everyone to vote and i think
it's so important to make that
distinction because not one republican
voted for voting rights in the united
states house of representatives the last
time they had a chance when they had the
two bills that came to the floor not not
one not even adam kinzinger and liz
cheney which are you know darlings right
now because of what they're doing on the
select committee um but not one
republican vote and it only says uh all
the laws that they're trying to pass in
the states even like texas or georgia
and some other states missouri's doing
some you know they're really trying to
suppress the vote and i believe they're
actually suppressing their own vote like
you said some of these um you know
they're they're so hellbent on a
suppression that they might be
suppressing their own vote but democrats
literally are saying with this opt-in
our opt-out situation that you're
talking about you're literally saying i
want every single person to have the
ability and the ease of voting so we
know what our electorate looks like
right like we want to hash these issues
out this is the way government works and
if everyone gives their opinion by
giving their vote to who they want to do
that then we will get to a place to
where people aren't so disappointed
because i feel like
the republican voter quote unquote right
because i i think i think republicans
would vote for you and especially in
texas after the electrical grid
situation after the january 6
situation um they would look and say
well maybe maybe there is someone who's
not so radical um who is focused on the
issues that maybe mean something to me
right so giving every single person
whether it be republican democrat
christian muslim white black whoever it
is women men you get the right to vote
you get the right to go mark your ballot
i think that's the most important thing
that democrats are fighting for everyone
to vote not just for democrats to vote
but on the other side it seems that way
so what will you do
if you go to the texas state legislator
because you're really in a battle for
not just the texas state laws but also
those state laws affect the national
races because we see so many republicans
really trying to change these races to
where maybe one person in the state or a
handful of people in the state get to
decide what those votes in the state
want to be like they can just overturn a
vote right oh well or not even that but
also just bills right like you look at
you know the anti-abortion bill and it's
like that
you know going up with the supreme court
rover roe versus wade like we have a
moment that could change
that one state bill can change the
national
uh outcome for every state that now
wants to say that this is illegal and
you can't do it and the the precedent is
texas right so it's like
you know it does have a national effect
even on a local level you know yeah and
i think the the number one way to sort
of garner support from the across the
aisle is having relationships right
that's how i started in hewlett city
council as soon as i got elected i mean
i knew all six of them were republican
but at the end of the day it doesn't i
mean they are really really amazing
people they're like moderate republicans
who understand how government needs to
work and so i started a relationship
with them right i have met with them
individually so that way i could have a
relationship with them at the end of the
day we're humans first right and humans
are social being so if i talk to you
about my story and you talk to me about
your story we get connected now if we go
we may have some something we may not
agree with obviously right even i don't
agree everything with my wife as well
right so you know
but you'll be respectful about it right
right at the dice when we're voting for
something we're respectful we're saying
we're saying our opinion and i always
put my opinion back to what is best for
you list residents not what is best for
democrats or not what's best for a
republican so i never threw the partisan
rhetoric in so i think when you start
developing relationships people right
now you'd be surprised i have a state
elected state representative that's
republican party
he is helping me in my campaign can you
believe that
right
a democrat when there is already a
republican candidate on the other side
in my race
right i mean it's it's amazing why why
because i reached out to him you'd be
surprised how many people just say hey
i'm not gonna i'm never gonna reach out
to republicans or i'm not gonna reach
out to democrats why
we're all americans at the end of the
day right that's great right
i think we focus too much especially
after 2016 on what differences that we
have between us
as opposed to the commonalities if we
focus on the commonalities we'll realize
we have so much more in common and it
will unite us as opposed to dividing us
and that's what like the the template
that our former president worked on and
i think that's what i have a problem
with right what whoever is he as a
person it doesn't matter the other day
he really spewed a lot of hatred and he
brought hateful
hatred inside people right and they were
talking in their kitchen table or in
their homes now they're on the streets
and that's why january 6th happened no
no wonder why this happened right
because there's so much hate i mean like
i'm at the polls right now
i i
like a lot of people are coming in to
vote i asked them hey are you voting the
democratic primary i would never vote
for democrat they were saying i would
never vote for a democrat i'm going to
hunt democrats down we need to hunt them
down and uh you know so i think the the
hatred needs to stop right i think we
can work with republicans and we can
work with democrats we can work with
everybody so long as being respectful of
each other and that's what i bring
people down to say hey look let's just
make sure that we we have a good
conversation as opposed to being mean
because meanness is not going to solve
anything right you're just going to hate
me i'm you know and i'm gonna be like
why am i being hated i'm still as
american as you are right it doesn't
matter if i was not born here right and
so i remind them of that i think that's
how we can get legislation passed
because if you tied back to the
constituents that's when they'll say oh
yeah this makes sense it's not about the
party right it should be country before
the party stayed before the party right
i well i i appreciate that your outlook
especially in the local race that you
have there and 92 sounds like they would
be
very very very lucky lucky to have you
and keep up the hard work so tell us
before we go where where do we find
everything uh we'll we'll do this up
fancy and we'll put all the stuff in
afterwards but tell us where where where
do where do people go to find your
campaign where do they go to find you um
and tell us all that good good shameless
plug there
so you can find us on bhojani for texas
that's bsnboy h o j a n i f o r t e x
texas.com
and uh you you can you know reach out to
us i can even give my cell phone if if
need be uh you know there's a lot of
information that we have we're all on
twitter facebook instagram even tick
tock i did a tech talk actually
because my my daughter keeps me you know
young with that all that stuff right
when i was knocking on doors i was
putting a yard sign so i was just
telling them hey i just knocked on the
door and they you know i'm having great
you know interactions with houses and 92
residents and so i'm putting a yard sign
it had 50 000 views
wow wow like oh like that's great and i
just got gabe's getting jealous gabe's
getting jealous
and i'm so gay probably as more viewers
i just got started and ticked on side
i'm just getting some but again we're on
all platform because i want to add youth
perspective as well that's why i'm on
talk because we need to listen to that
i'm a boy scout leader so i as i go
around speaking to boy scouts you know
number one thing they tell me is climate
change right and we're not paying
attention to that as much as a state or
as a country but i mean i think that
that that says a lot especially to your
point earlier about the pipeline right
like making sure that you're able to uh
generate interest and engagement from
the youth because those are gonna be
people who then say you know what
it's time for me
to look out for the next generation you
know and actually put their foot forward
and and run for you know a local
statewide national level seed
yep absolutely
well we really appreciate you joining us
and come back anytime um we we would
love to hear more of your story yeah one
last thing i'll say if you don't mind
yeah go ahead and early voting is going
on right now so people can vote actually
as soon as possible uh you know through
february 25th
at multiple uh tarrant county locations
so if you live in tarrant county you can
vote anywhere in tarrant county so if
you work more in like west fort worth
but you live in euless you can vote in
euless or you can vote in fort worth
anywhere and election day is gonna be
march first that's gonna be the last
opportunity to vote and i would really
appreciate your support and your vote
thank you great great and one more thing
i i forgot to tell you so the the cities
that are involved in in uh in house of
92 because it's they've gerrymandered it
so much so you know i want to make sure
at least i save the cities so it's
euless bedford hearst
fort worth
arlington and grand prairie so these are
the six cities if you live in these six
cities you'll be able to vote in the
democrat and pembroke primary on the
houses tonight too
awesome awesome and and all around the
state of texas is early voting on those
days correct yes yes that's exactly so
get out get out go vote um and show your
support for all the pro-democracy
candidates out there thank you so much
for joining us again come back anytime
we'll talk to you very soon my friend
very soon and good luck on your race and
and stay busy out there okay thank you
very much
thank you